[Music]
coming up on today's show we're going to
be talking about life after cancer
treatment
how to have hard conversations with your
parents how to step in when your brother
or sister
is hurting your parents and we're going
to be talking about grief
stay tuned
hey good folks and happy people i am
john and this
is the dr john delony show a show
for you about you and with you we're
talking about relationships relational
iq
your mental health teaching kids at home
school
that's turned into a walking disaster
we're going to talk about being a good
friend
people at the grocery store who seem
shocked when they get up to the front of
the line that oh they've got to pay and
then they start digging into the back of
their
pants or in their purse listen when you
go to the grocery store there's this
awesome exchange that happens
you take their stuff and you pay them
you give them stuff so let's get to the
front line and be prepared all right so
whatever whatever's going on in your
heart and your mind and your soul we're
talking about it here
if you're looking for honesty in a world
where truth doesn't seem
to exist anymore you've come to the
right place if you want a first or
second opinion i'm here to walk with you
give me a call at 1-844
that's 1-844-693-3291 you can also email
me at ask
john at ramseysolutions.com that's
ask john ramseysolutions.com
all right let's go straight to the
phones today we've got a lineup full of
good calls
let's see here let's go to joe in
british columbia brother joe how we
doing this morning
i'm doing well thanks um outstanding how
can i help man
so i'm 19 years old and earlier this
year i had to have
some chemotherapy treatments for a
cancer that was recurrent
thankfully as of right now i don't need
any more treatment but i find that i'm
feeling somewhat uh worn out and tired
and i have a tendency to suppress how i
feel a bit so i'm just wondering if you
have any advice for me
yeah so let's back up a little bit i've
got some thoughts here but i want to
hear more about your story man that
sounds like a tragic
frustrating out of nowhere turn here so
how did you find out you
needed chemotherapy that you had cancer
yeah so it it started about a a year
earlier so in 2019
i was just finishing up high school and
then i
found out that i had sort of a
i had testicular cancer so i had to have
surgery for that
and then after they monitored me for a
few months they they realized that it
had
spread to my lungs so i had to have
chemotherapy treatments
earlier this year around february and
march uh joe can i just
stop i i without any i want to have a
human moment here just want to let you
know that sucks man
18 year olds are supposed to be thinking
about who they're going to marry
and their next steps and going to
college and getting a job and they
should not be worrying about testicular
cancer
and they should not be worrying about
their mortality at 19 brother that sucks
and i hate that for you man
walk me through this the first time you
realized oh man i've
this doesn't feel right something's
growing on me that's not supposed to be
there i don't feel good and then you go
to the doctor and they give you this
diagnosis walk me through that
yeah um it all happened pretty quick
like i
i went to see my family doctor and then
like a week later they did some
testing and then it was like just like
bombarded with different phone calls
that i needed to do this and that and
that and then like
basically i think it was just a few days
after i found out that they had
that they did surgery it was all like
really quick it happened in like maybe a
two week span
from when i first went to my family
doctor too when i
had surgery so it all was kind of just a
bit of a blur almost
so now that it's settled do they have
they announced that you are
currently not showing any signs of
cancer
yeah that's that's correct so the recent
tests that i've done
have come back clear so so now they're
just kind of monitoring me and
so does that give you some some peace in
your heart some
yeah it does but uh there's always the
chance that
you know it comes back like they don't
really say you're cancer-free until like
five years later but right right um
but no for the most part i i do feel at
peace about that
so you're you're frustrated you're
exhausted talk me through that how you
feeling these days
um like physically i'm feeling fine and
i guess that's maybe
the weird part is that like i feel like
almost like the mental part of it kind
of hit me
later like as i was going through
chemotherapy treatments i
i was feeling obviously terribly
terrible
physically but uh maybe i didn't really
realize the mental
toll of it and now i almost feel like
i'm i'm feeling that part of it
once i've come through that if that
makes sense absolutely
so you got a
gift and it's not a gift that anybody
wants that's a gift that anybody asked
for
but you got to lean your head over the
other side
most 18 and 19 year olds don't get to
understand this idea that they are
mortal
and that tomorrow's not guaranteed for
any of us
and when i say gift man i hesitate to
even use that word because i know what
you went through was traumatic and awful
but this sense of whoo this sense of
anxiety this
low-level hum this level burn of
whoa man i might my body might be
attacking itself and i might be dying
right
um you got to you got to experience that
man and most people don't get to see
that
especially your age let me ask you this
what are you doing now are you going to
school are you working
are you living at home in your mom's
basement just playing video games and
eating cheetos like what are you doing
uh so i've been going i've been going to
uh school the whole time during this
i've been going to university the whole
time
okay and now i'm i'm it's all online
right now but
so i am in my mother's basement but
that's fantastic so joe what do you want
to do who do you want to become
what do you want to do professionally
what do you want to
what do you want this this cancer to
have represented 10 years from now 15
years from now 20 years from now
um well i'm i'm going to school to
become a teacher so that's my
goal right now
as far as what this looks like 10 years
from now i don't know i guess maybe that
that me going through something
difficult helps me
you know understand other people's
difficulties and helps them
maybe walk through similar things or
yeah trials of their own so you're
experiencing this thing
called grief and grief
is heavy and it's not fun
and it sucks it's just not fun but it's
something that we all go through and
that we all experience
and we live in a culture brother joe
that doesn't
honor grief that just tries to wallpaper
over it and says look man
you're healed they'll no go play
baseball and we we just
try to pass through this natural process
and so
in a robust otherwise healthy 18 to 19
year old body
and a guy with a character like you who
wants to be a teacher wants to help
other people
um dude when you got this diagnosis
and you mentioned this flurry you were
in it your body went to fight or flight
and dude
it went to war it battled and it held up
for you and it held up with the chemo
treatments
and my guess is most of the folks who i
know who got cancer
um end up making sure everyone around
them is okay most of the time right did
you get a lot of calls and texts and oh
my gosh
and you ended up having to make sure
your mom and dad or your friends are
doing fine that happened to you
yeah that's actually kind of a yeah a
lot of people would like come up to me
like how you doing and i'm like i'm
doing all right yeah you would
definitely
take care of them right that's a common
a common thing yeah
yeah i was kind of reassuring them
yeah yeah so the last person you got to
really sit down and look in the mirror
with
and experience this near-death car wreck
which was cancer was you and that's what
your body's doing right now man
it is exhaling it is blowing out the
and for people some people experience
that as as this low level i hate to use
the word because it's so over dramatized
and over
um over diagnosed but this low-level
depression this low-level
literally depression this things have
just gotten mushed down because for a
year for two years you had to
you had to push your feelings down you
had to push your fears down and you had
to just go fight cancer
you had to do what the next doctor said
the next doctor said and you had to
recover from surgery
you had to recover from chemo you had to
make sure your mom was okay and all your
buddies are doing good
and then you start having these little
bitty like what's tomorrow going to be
like when am i going to be quote-unquote
cancer-free all that stuff right
and now the smoke is cleared the
surgery's over
you've been given a clean bill they're
going to be watching you every couple of
months for the next four or five years
and now your body is starting to settle
into this grieving moment
this idea of whoa that was close
i had the big c i had the cancer i'm 19.
it's not supposed to happen like that
and you're right it's not unfortunately
it happens more and more and more
and it happens to anybody at any time
cancer doesn't play favorites with
anybody it sucks it's a demon
it's ugly but you're on the other side
of it so here's what i want you to do
with this idea of grief
and i want you to write yourself a
letter
congratulating yourself for getting
through this moment i want you to write
the letter dear joe
dude we made it and i want you to
talk about your fears i want you to talk
about your
frustrations with this and i want you to
read this letter to one or two of your
buddies
i want you to read this letter to some
people that you trust it might even have
to be a counselor if you don't have
close buddies i'm assuming that you do
man
but i want you to read the letter to
them just so that you are able to
express this and share this with
somebody else
and then as you make your way through
this grieving process you're going to
find yourself frustrated you're going to
find yourself angry
you're going to find yourself having all
these emotions that probably you've
never experienced before
make sure you've got other people to
walk alongside you during this process
you can be vulnerable with
you're going to have great great days
where you really celebrate being well
and healed and you're going to have days
when you wake up and you just remember
the car wreck
you just remember that diagnosis day
coming out of surgery looking at your
mom and hoping everything's going to be
okay
and then comes the magic part that david
kessler talks about
finding meaning and over the next two
three four years
you're going to start wrapping your head
around this and figuring out ways that
you can support and care and love other
people if it's as a teacher
what a gift man you're going to have
this idea of empathy for your students
moving forward that most teachers don't
have
because most of us don't get to look
over the edge and see oh man
none of us are guaranteed tomorrow we're
just not
um most of us don't get to do that until
we're older
and you got to look on the other side so
joe
i am i am honored to talk to you
congratulations on getting through this
nightmare scenario
and our thoughts and prayers are with
you as you continue to heal and get
better
and then brother go find meaning man
after you've grieved this go find
meaning go make meaning it's going to be
awesome
you're uh you're awesome and i think the
word awesome i have a buddy in texas who
tells me to quit saying
the word awesome because he says it's
what high school teachers use like yeah
dude that's awesome
but some people are just awesome and
joe's joe's awesome all right let's go
to courtney in daytona beach
courtney what is up hi how are you
i'm so good courtney how are you good
i'm so excited to have this opportunity
to speak with you
and me with you go for it what's up
okay so i need advice on
how to tell my parents that i had a baby
that i placed for adoption
and the back story to that is in
december of 2018 i was only 19 years old
i was very unexpected i found out as i
was having him
and so we decided that the best the best
route would be
adoption and that has worked out
absolutely beautifully
i can't complain about that at all but
now i'm kind of stuck in a place where
i think i really need to tell them in
order to keep moving forward
but my boyfriend isn't as open with it
and so i don't want to really be too
disrespectful against like
his wishes on the topic so i'm really
like stuck
wow there's a lot there okay so number
one thank you for calling let's
unpack this a little bit so a couple
years ago you had a baby
you placed it for adoption and you carry
the baby full full-term places to
adoption
and baby's doing well are you still in
contact with
the adoptive parents or is your baby i
have a
you know i have a great relationship i
talk to her probably once a week if
maybe two weeks but we have a very good
relationship wow how remarkable and
they're good folks good parents and you
feel wonderful about your
baby being there yes i have my view on
it is
this was meant to happen that's just how
everything's worked out very well
on my side of it that's that's
incredible okay so
is this boyfriend you have the is that
the
father of this child or somebody new
okay so you all are still together
yes how long has have you all been
together um
three years in december three years okay
and so why aren't you married yet why
don't you just say dude this is this is
the guy let's just call it
i don't know we've honestly talked about
it but
i don't know i don't know i think it
really has to do with me because i'm
like i'm tv young
this and that but i have a bunch of i
guess
qualifications of what i think i need to
be before i could be married
is what it is name some of them for me i
honestly want
my debt paid off which i know is like
you can do it together but i also
i'm not i'm only 20 now he's a little
bit older
i feel like you need a house first you
need to be in the position to buy a
house
together just little stuff like that
which i know isn't true but that's what
i think
hinders it so those things are all real
but you've kind of knocked everything
out of order because you have those
three things and then you have a kid
right and so y'all went out of order
there
um yeah so as a couple y'all have
experienced a lot of things that
most couples experience after they've
committed to one another for the rest of
their lives
how did he feel about this adoption
um he kind of you know he was very
supportive and he was there for me he
still has been but i think over time
it's been harder for him than it has
been for me like i've coped with it very
well
and he i don't think has like it's we
don't really talk about
it it's kind of uncomfortable to talk
about with him which is like
kind of makes me sad because i find it
to be such a happy thing like if
you know if it had to happen take the
time to joy in it
and kind of go with it i feel like for
him it's a little bit harder how is he
struggling
what does harder mean i just he doesn't
talk about it like i'll get pictures
printed out or i got like
in in preparation of telling my parents
i ordered a photo book and i was like
here you go that's one step closer and i
still haven't looked at it and i think
it's just hard because he's
about he's a late
20s so i think it's for him it's more
like i should have been ready
yeah i should have been at the age type
of thing yeah
so he is probably experiencing quite a
bit of shame
i had a i had a child and
in my mid to late 20s and i wasn't quote
unquote man enough to take care of that
kid
yeah i think that's exactly what it is
because he also doesn't
reach like he's we're all friendly with
the parents but he doesn't go out of his
way to like reach out to them
his thing is you know if they want to
talk to me they can send me a message
it's not like in a bad way but i think
it is he just doesn't like to
that sounds pretty mature i mean that
can't do yeah that sounds pretty
immature
for somebody who created a human right
uh and again that goes that's the
responsibility of
hooking up is the result is you could
have
a human life right and then you've got
to be able to deal with that
all right so yeah it sounds like he's
going through a lot here's here's my
thought here
um so he's how long did you say he's 28
yeah okay so i want to back out a 26
year old hooked up with an 18 year old
and y'all had a kid and
i don't want to minimize the the magic
love making experience that a 26 year
old an 18 year old are going through but
y'all hooked up and you had a kid
and you did a noble and remarkable thing
and you blessed a family with that
beautiful baby
and they're doing great and you are able
to see that for the blessing that it is
good for you when it comes to telling
your parents
you're not married to this dude you all
have been dating for a while you're not
married to this guy and so i'm going to
tell you he didn't get a vote
and if this secret between you and your
family is hanging
there like a giant weight around your
neck
which i'm confident that it is it's my
opinion that that secrets kill
people they drown people and i would
recommend talking to your folks
there's not going to be a cute way to do
this or a
um a you know like making a book or try
this isn't going to be a fun beautiful
conversation this is going to be one of
those conversations that you
let your parents know ahead of time we
need to have a hard talk
and that we're going to have a hard
conversation and i'm going to
need you and mom like mom and dad and
y'all to be direct and
paying attention to me and then we're
going to go have breakfast somewhere and
just let them know i want you to know
they're going to be devastated they're
going to be heartbroken not that
there is a grandkid that they don't know
about that will be a thing here's what
they're going to be devastated about
that their baby girl went through
something so hard and they weren't there
for them
they were there for you does that make
sense
yeah no i've spoken to some of my older
siblings about it and they said the same
thing they're like they're not gonna be
mad at you because i was like
are they gonna be mad and they're like
no they're gonna be you know probably
disappointed or upset that they didn't
find out sooner
yeah they're gonna be disappointed that
they didn't walk with you through this
journey right it's a magical
transformation and then
then the babies all the stuff right and
they're gonna probably say things like
well we would have helped and
now they're gonna deal with somebody
else raising in their mind their
grandkid
right and that their teenage daughter
had to make this
heavy heavy decision all on their own
but here's the thing it is what it is so
i want you to not go into this
conversation with any sort of fantasy
any sort of mythological there's going
to be confetti come down everybody's
gonna hug
and they're gonna it's just gonna be a
hard conversation gear yourself up for
it but the hard conversation is still
the right conversation
and it sounds like you're tired of
this secret and i'm telling you right
now is no matter how hard this
conversation goes you're gonna feel a
burden lifted off your heart in your
soul
it's definitely hard i feel like i'm
living like two lives because i get
pictures i get updates and it's like i
yeah right now it's like you can't share
that with them and i find so much joy in
it so i feel like
they would in a way too to know that i
i did make the right choice because i
have such an involvement still and it's
not like i
made this decision and then i never
heard about it again
that's right um would your adoptive
parents are they open to your parents
visiting
or you're all just we've kind of
discussed it and she left it
the mom left it to if if he ever asked
about them
okay he would be the one to do it she
wouldn't want to push it on him
okay i think that's really wise and good
good for her
yeah he looks like you picked a
wonderful family so the challenge for
your parents is they're going to want to
see the baby
and they're going to want to see their
likeness representing their grandkids
there's just going to be a piece of
their heart out running around in the
universe that they can't see and hug and
touch
right and so just know that's going to
be hard
but also know that it's again it's the
right conversation to have
and so i here here's the steps in order
number one
i would let them know ahead of time
don't just show up at their house one
afternoon drop a bomb on them
let them know hey we need to have a hard
conversation and
i'm gonna come to your house so we're
gonna do this or we're gonna go get
pancakes together and we're gonna have
this hard conversation
you know what they're gonna think
they're gonna think that you're pregnant
now and they're gonna think that you
need to have a quick shotgun wedding
with
this older guy that they may or may not
like they're not gonna
be expecting that you already had a baby
and the baby is
one and a half or two years old and
doing well with an adoptive family
so you're gonna surprise them understand
they're gonna be heartbroken they're
gonna they're gonna
cry and that doesn't mean what you did
is is not the right thing
and then be willing to be willing to
heal that relationship with your parents
they're going to feel like they let you
down they're going to feel like you let
them know it's just going to be messy
it's just going to be messy and messy
and
hard doesn't mean it's the wrong thing
you're going to have to grieve this with
your parents here's the deal your
parents had a picture in their head
of what the grandkid was going to be
like the first grandkid and they've
imagined it they're going to
imagine themselves of buying all this
shenanigans for this baby right
and coming over and and they're going to
have to
reframe their picture they're gonna have
to grieve it they're gonna have to
grieve
this this this new world that they're in
that you're gonna just drop on them at a
denny's at nine o'clock on some saturday
morning
you're gonna have to grieve a new
relationship with your parents
you're also going to have to grieve a
transitioning relationship with this guy
you're 20 he's 28 he's almost got a
decade on you
at some point you're gonna have to
decide this is the guy for me or not
he's gonna have to deal with the grief
of his child um he's gonna have to deal
with the grief of
um i should have been there i should
have raised my own
kid and i didn't um and that doesn't
mean that was the wrong thing but he's
gonna have his own thoughts he's in the
more he
hides from that stuff the deeper that
wound's going to get the more that
infection is going to fester and it's
just going to end up
spraying all the people he loves too so
he's going to have to do his own work
and so i keep talking about the first
two calls here i've talked about grief
and i've talked about grief and i've
talked about grief
really quickly um let's talk about grief
for a second
kublar ross came up with this model
years and years ago
back in the late 60s early 70s she wrote
this book on death and dying
and it was really a discussion this book
was a discussion
of the five stages of grief she came up
with and they are denial
anger bargaining depression and
acceptance
so when somebody dies in your life you
deny it
then you get angry you get pissed off
and then you start barging with god you
start bargaining with the people around
you i'll be nicer if
and then you go through this depression
you just get through in that black hole
of grief
that if anyone is if you've lost
somebody you know what i'm talking about
and then you get to the acceptance stage
where you start to
rebloom you start to regrow you just
realize this is what this
is and we often think about you know
death that's the thing that we grieve
right kubler-ross
these stages were initially designed for
people who
weren't grieving the losses of loved
ones or broken relationships it was
written for
it was designed for people who were
grieving their own impending death
she was with people who were dying and
then in 2019 david kessler
who was who studied with her i think he
was one of her research assistants he
wrote
one of my top five most important books
of my life
he wrote um it's called finding meaning
the stick
sixth stages of grief and we'll put that
in the show notes here
we'll put both these books in the show
notes but if you have to pick up one
book
over the next few months pick up finding
meaning by david kessler especially in
these times it's a remarkable book
on grief is so much bigger than
somebody's dying or you died grief is
about
any sort of what you thought was gonna
happen is not gonna happen
right you thought you were gonna be an
astronaut it didn't work out that way
you thought you were gonna meet some
romantic prince and he turned out to be
an abusive jerk
you thought that my picture of my first
grandkid
is going to be this we're going to hold
this baby
and it's going to be an easy birth and
my daughter's going to be
healthy and she's going to the father of
this child is going to be this wonderful
guy and he's going to be there
and then all of a sudden you find out
that your first grandkid was
adopted underneath you you didn't know
and it's somewhere else
all of those things are grief it's just
that the picture you thought was going
to be your tomorrow has changed
and the longer we go through life not
acknowledging that
the more it festers within us there
becomes a gap and we fill that gap with
all kinds of addictive behaviors
busyness numbing behaviors
drinking well all kinds of crazy things
we run around right
and so what kessler brings to the table
here is
after acceptance right after you just
make peace with it
that's not enough there's this next step
this sixth step
and that is what are you going to do as
a result of
right are you going to become an
advocate for adoptive families
are you going to be an advocate for
parents having great relationships with
their teenage kids
so that they feel safe to come home and
talk to you are you going to
become somebody who is really
involved in aaa because you lost a loved
one to
alcoholism or drug abuse whatever the
thing is how are you going to make
meaning how are you going to transform
your heart and the hearts of those
around you
because you went through this right an
important thing about these stages
is they're not linear right sometimes
people die and you get angry
and then you deny it and then you go
into the black hole or somebody passes
away and you go into the black hole or
you just
randomly get dumped and whoosh you feel
like you've just been
stuck under water right
eventually you begin to breathe again if
you've got people walking alongside you
eventually you get to
exhale again the sun comes up
the buds that were broken off begin to
begin to bloom
the world turns green again and here's
the thing
here's a great quote from this this
kessler book here's a here it is
when we are grieving we want to stay in
the harbor
it's a good place to be for a while it's
where we refuel rebuild repair but in
the same way ships are meant to sail
we are meant to eventually leave our
safe harbor to take
the risk of loving again to find new
adventures
to live a life after loss and maybe
even to help another right this is what
finding meaning is
is about this is what stopping we
thought 2020 was going to be this thing
and this thing and this thing and this
thing
it's not i thought i was going to get to
have this awesome new job promotion
and and i'm not i'm homeschooling my kid
i've got a bandana on that i take off
just for this zoom meeting and then i
put it back on i'm
i've just got to grieve what i thought
was going to be so that i can come to
the present and deal with what's now
and then over time i'm going to accept
where i'm at i'm going to
sometimes bite down on my mouthpiece and
just go in swinging other times i'm
going to
let the things go that i can't control
and over time we're going to make
meaning
we're going to make meaning and we're
going to continue to live the story the
best way that we can
so thank you so so much for that call
courtney
i'll be thinking about you i would love
love
love courtney call me back after that
that conversation with your folks
if all three of you want to call me back
i'd love to talk to your parents too i
want to hear how that conversation goes
i want to hear how y'all
work together to make a plan for
tomorrow thank you so so much for the
call let's take one more call let's go
to jessica in grand rapids michigan
jessica how are you hi john i'm good how
are you
outstanding outstanding how can i help
hi so i am calling because i have
a sibling a brother that basically came
home from college with a mental
breakdown
it's now been five and a half years he's
been living with my parents
and basically um
his making their life health so um
the rest of the siblings and i have
talked about possibly in
doing like an intervention because my
parents don't know how to set boundaries
with them
and just telling them how we feel about
the situation because we also
feel like we're losing them so i just
thought i'd give you a call and see if
you had any advice if that's even
something we should do if we should just
sit back and watch
this unfold for the next who knows how
long or
if we should tell them how we feel and
maybe help them with some resources
yeah so tell me when you say mental
breakdown five and a half years ago
was it just a anxiety fit i don't like
taking tests is he schizophrenic like
paint me a picture of that
uh well he basically he was working and
doing school a lot
and didn't sleep and so mentally
couldn't take
all of the pressure um
misbehaved a little bit not terrible but
the school
basically released them to you can go
home we don't need you to finish
your semester um and then
found out through various different
things that he does have some mental
health
uh disorders he has a personality
disorder like borderline
um and his
he does have anxiety and depression on
top of that that's been medicated but
this summer he went to chase this girl
who didn't like him on his medications
and so now we've seen a decline in his
mental health
as well as uh there's a lot of guilt on
my parents part he went through some
medical
trauma earlier in his life and so i
think they feel like they have to
provide him whatever he wants yeah so
here's the thing you're right on you and
your brothers
and sisters are right on um
there comes a point when
loved ones our brother our sister
sometimes it's our dad
or our mom there comes a moment when
our loved one becomes a grown man who's
making my mom cry
right and yes he's my brother yes i love
him
yes he's got some challenges yes he went
through some nonsense some
some crap as a kid but right now
he's a 25 year old or 26 year old who's
breaking up my parents marriage
who is keeping my dad from sleeping a a
full night of sleep
who is playing my mom like an accordion
and making my mom
his hair turned gray making her cry and
there is a moment as a parent
um do you have kids of your own yes okay
so you know
i'm just talking to you parent to parent
here there's moments when we get so far
down our own rabbit hole trying to care
for our kids that we lose the forest
from the trees right
and what a i like your word what an
intervention can do for your parents is
let them know that
they're not alone you and your brothers
and sisters can pull them out of
whatever river they're drowning in help
dry them off
and then offer them some resources but
the probably the most important resource
you're going to offer them
is that you've got their back
right that you love them you support
them you're going to teach them how to
draw boundaries you're going to support
whatever boundaries they draw
and that might have ugly consequences
for your brother for a season
right and people with borderline
personality disorder
they're they are brilliant and lovely
and hilarious
and hellacious to work with because
you are the greatest person who has ever
lived until you are the worst person who
has ever lived right
exactly mom and dad are the most
wonderful people until they've ruined my
life and you guys suck and i hate you
and i'm just gonna
quit digging my meds and go off cause
she loves me more and this girl is gonna
be the greatest girl who
ever lived until she's not right and
that's
such as the up and downs of folks who
are on borderline personality disorder
and don't work really really hard
to come to terms with these
rollercoaster fireball emotions that
rage through their bodies
and so yes at the end of the day you
need to get your parents out of a
burning house
and they need to hear love and support
from you and from your
siblings my my recommendation for that
would be to let them know hey we're
going to set up a time that we all want
to meet whether that's in person or
because of the
the the current medical climate we're
going to do a
zoom meeting and somebody needs to that
they trust
there's always that one sibling that
kind of takes the lead it might be you
that they said hey call the knucklehead
on the radio and see what he has
to say but whoever the the brother or
sister is that that has their trust the
most
um can call in and say listen um we love
you and
you gotta start drawing some boundaries
because we're worried about you
and mom we're worried about you and dad
and we love you
and we don't want to see our brother
hurting y'all anymore
absolutely absolutely how does that how
does that hit you
it's just validation i think because we
i mean we've been watching this unfold
for the last five years so we're very
um we feel like we've lost something too
with our parents that they've they're so
focused on him
and unable to see how it's hurting
everyone else so
well here's the thing beware of this
after five and a half years
caring for their hurting son has become
an identity for your parents
they have found meaning in their hurt
and they have found meaning in their
pain
for parents who like you said he had
medical trauma as a kid he's probably
experienced some hard things as a kid
sometimes this lashing that parents
subject themselves to especially with
their adult kids
when they won't draw boundaries there's
some weird
ugly tiny demon in the back of their
hearts and minds that say you deserve
this
this is because of and so expect some
resistance
expect some yeah but somebody need like
expect that
and just know going in all all four of
you is there four there's four of you
right
that y'all go in as a united front that
says mom and dad this is enough
this is enough and we're gonna help you
draw boundaries so whatever resources
y'all can come up with
either locally for him um
really the boundaries for for a 25 year
old are gonna be
you've got three months and then you're
out and then some you all need to rotate
going to visit mom and dad or calling
mom and dad and letting them know that
when they get this torrent
of um this torrent of borderline
response which is going to be your
you're going to make me homeless you're
the worst you're throwing me out of my
ear you don't care about them you don't
love me all that stuff
partridge into pear tree that your
parents are constantly being filled up
you're holding their arms up in the
desert as they are desperate for water
and you're helping them out to get
through this season and then they've got
to kick them out
they got to change the locks on the
house if it gets to that probably he'll
throw a temper tantrum and take off
and then they're going to have to hold
boundaries and the boundaries might be
when you get a job
we'll help you out um if you need
support buying your medication if you
can show us that you're on your
medication we'll help you out whatever
that's going to look like but
i trust you and your brothers and
sisters do that but yeah 100 you've got
my blessing you'll need to step in
help your mom and dad out of the out of
the river they're drowning
they've made an identity out of treading
water and it's time for folks who love
them to step in and help
what a great call thank you so much
jessica you're a saint and you and your
brothers and sisters are awesome i'd
love to know how that conversation goes
so please call me back
let me know how the intervention goes
how your parents take it if they take it
well if they don't take it well i'd love
to hear how they are doing
so as we wrap up today's show um here's
the thing i talk a lot about the
greatest band this the greatest band
that and now i'm starting to get the
direct messages and the
the instagrams and the youtube comments
saying like oh dude we get the joke huh
so i i haven't been totally honest
sometimes i have sometimes i haven't
this is for real this is for real i
think these are
a few of the greatest songwriters
working today and i mean this and if you
know who they are
i hope you can hear the sincerity of my
voice i'll be back to being a clown on
the next podcast
in the next youtubes but listen this to
these two brothers
are songwriters extraordinaires they're
they're probably part
prophets they are speaking truth into
the world in a way that um only they can
this is one of the greatest songs
literally ever written and every time i
hear it i
have to stop and catch myself because
i'll get choked up a little bit
this is from the gleam 2 record it's
written by the avett brothers and it's
called murder in the city
and the words go like this if i get
murdered in the city
don't go revenging in my name one person
dead from such is plenty
no need to go get locked away when i
leave your arms the things that i think
of
no need to get over alarmed i'm coming
home
if i get murdered in the city go read
the letter in my desk
i'm getting goosebumps now don't bother
with all my belongings
pay attention to the list make sure my
sister knows i loved her
god almighty i get choked up every time
make sure my sister knows i loved her
make sure my mother knows the same
always remember there was
nothing worth sharing like the love that
let us share our name
always remember there was nothing worth
sharing
like the love that let us share our name
this is the dr john deloney show
you